alright doctor let's just let's just
have some fun it is big finish time once
again and I've got to kind of pick up on
something that I addressed I don't know
how far back because I'm recording this
in advance at the time that I have
finished listening at these things and I
don't know how far down the line I'm
gonna punt this could be a couple of
months could be a lot longer don't know
it's in the cam regardless now so who
knows people of the future so I'm gonna
talk about the episodes from the Fourth
Doctor adventures second season in Big
Finish that I didn't already cover
because in an earlier video I'll drop a
link up there I talked about the four
that sort of for my continuous story
dealing with the villain of Cuthbert
play by David Warren come and that made
up four out of the seven of these
stories and so I now need to talk about
the other three and these are all
completely self-contained standalone
stories so and they're so they're
completely locked off and there is a
really a thematic through line in this
case but they're also on the shorter
side these are only about an hour a pop
whereas like say the main range ones
that I had been dealing with mostly up
to this point usually more in the range
of two hours or you know close to it so
I didn't feel like I could get a full
episode out of each one of these
individually so I'm just gonna move it
together
so first up oh and I also mentioned all
of these and the reason I got into them
was because of it marked the return of
the late Mary Tam as the original
incarnation of Romana so we have Tom
Baker's the fourth doctor
we have Mary Tammuz Romana we also have
k9 who is not fully utilized in all of
these stories he's kind of out of
commission for some of them or at least
one of them and you know and but he's
still there he still
he still works well so that's and this
is all a grand scope of the Doctor Who
timeline something that that is this all
takes place following the end of the key
to time season from Tom Baker's run
where that version of Romana
first appears so they are theoretically
on the run from the guardian that
storyline doesn't really enter into
things at all it just kind of gets
mentioned every now and then basically
just sort of place this timeline
timeline wise so first of these stories
is called the antimatter and it is
basically PG woodhouse by way of Doctor
Who it is it is as if doctor who has
dropped into sort of this comedy of
manners with these you know stuck-up
upper class British people go oh did you
know my aunt has always been saying that
it is definitely a time for me to find
out oh lady who can take care of me and
she would so love to meet you that it's
that kind of kind of interaction and
those kinds of characters and it's
actually just a lot of fun that's kind
of it's a running thing with all three
of these stand-alones and it's just fun
settings and fun vibes that the doctor
and Romana get dropped into for each of
these stories so that's the general vibe
of the antimatter and sort of what's
going on here is you have a I'm gonna
say young gentleman it's really tough to
place his age based off strictly his
voice but you know somebody of marrying
age in Victorian England era who as it
opens he is taking a young woman to meet
his aunt to see if his aunt approves of
him getting married to her and well
there's some weirdness going on with
this aunt and and that young woman does
not survive this weirdness and then this
young man with a little bit of mind
control and tinkering and suggestion
going on from the aunt and her her
household staff he then sets out again
to find another young woman in his mind
because
oh you know it's time that I got married
and you know but not really kind of
realizing these basically on the hunt on
behalf of his aunt and he then ends up
encountering Romana who is not dumb cuz
you would think oh my god she just goes
with this guy you know to go meet this
on or how stupid is she she's not then
she's trying to embrace the era which is
something the doctor you know recommend
that she do she's she's not she doesn't
feel threatened by this guy so you just
say well you know why not you know well
I'll just kind of jump in and experience
you know at this point in time this
point in uh in Earth history and
meanwhile the doctor is kind of sort of
tracking down his own stuff and they
don't actually cross paths for much but
actually they almost don't cross paths
at all which makes it kind of funny
especially towards the end when when
they when things are wrapping up because
both the doctor and Romana I get
embroiled in what's going on and they're
both on at the same manor house but
never in the same location and never
encountering the same other characters
at the same time which means they both
have their own half of this adventure
and they both impact how it ends but
they don't realize the other one was
there so they both think they had a
completely solo adventure that the other
one missed out on it's actually kind of
cute and adorable and again works very
well with that sort of more farcical
sort of comedy of manners kind of style
so it's the sort of thing that I might
have felt was contrived but since that
is the vibe of the episode of this story
overall I think it's kind of fitting
like it's it's a it's goofy this I will
call this one probably the most
disposable of the three I'm gonna talk
about today so but it's still fun
especially if you have any kind of
enjoyment for that style of comedy which
if you don't if you have an inherent
dislike for that style of comedy
you may find it grating I didn't I'm not
a huge fan of that kind of stuff but I
appreciate it when it's done well and I
think it is here the next one up that is
the justice of Jiao
our jobs are can't remember how they
said it this one this is another period
piece so and this one actually includes
some characters from classic era Doctor
Who an episode that I story I haven't
actually seen yet but recurring from the
classic Tom Baker era story the towns of
Wang Qiang we have professor Lightfoot
and his associate Henry Gordon Jago now
again as I said I have not seen towns of
Wayne trying yet and I also know that
these guys have appeared in big finish
before they were popula enough to get
their own spin-off thing I hadn't heard
any of that before so this is actually
my very first time encountering these
characters and despite the fact that I
did feel a little bit like I was missing
a couple of components because there is
some reference to the Fagin you know the
dr. moons them and already knows them I
they still absolutely work for me these
guys are adorable they're there a little
bit there are a little bit Holmes and
Watson but just a little less sort of
stuffy you know a little more light and
fun than you usually get when you do
Holmes and Watson straight and and
they're quite an interesting pair and
they kind of split off again actually
from a really big chunk of this entire
second season of Fourth Doctor
adventures the doctor and Roman are
separated in this case Romano goes off
with Jago and the doctor is mostly with
Lightfoot so plot wise the doctor and
Romana are here tracing after you know
something that they encountered in the
child's going oh that's dangerous we
should find out what that was and so it
crashes and they they try and lend their
figuring stuff out and what they find
out is in the area at the moment there
is currently a pair of things going on
and both of which started up about a
month ago there is a vigilante in the
street known as the pugilist who has
been beating up street thugs and
criminals and there's also been a series
of
he's showing up in the morgue that
looked like they were cooked
they are both you know burned and
charred and just kind of steamed all the
way through so that's the the sort of
setup of what's going on and the this
kind of story it really works great in
the setting and this in this timeframe
and it it does have that viel of a feel
of one of the more rollicking kind of
Sherlock Holmes style adventures and the
supporting cast is solid a lot of
cockney voices in this which I like I
like the cockney accent just I'd like
how it sounds and so we because we're
dealing with sort of the the more
street-level criminal element a fair
amount of time we get a fair number of
those kinds of voices which I always
just enjoy Colonel why I just do so you
know there's some accidents just sound
good to you so I really did enjoy that
and like is that that this one really
does come down to the you know the
characters and it's it's just a lot of
fun listening to these people work it
out you know cuz the the doctor doesn't
have all the answers and he's sort of
bouncing off of Lightfoot a little bit
and then Jago who's very much out of his
depth but still you know trying to be a
little bit dashing and courageous around
Ramana and this just this wonderful you
know exasperation when things go wrong
Oh crumbs it's kind of adorable I'm
really lovable k9 isn't really in this
one I'm really at all does the one he's
kind of out of commission for because he
was badly damaged in the previous story
not be on T matter but the sands of life
and war with the lawn but I talked about
those in that earlier video so it just
it it works well it does a good job of
through audio getting you into that sort
of the foggy streets of London in the
Victorian era of vibe and it that's
that's a setting I always enjoy I have
an inherent enjoyment in that setting
and that's sort of true of all three of
these that I'm talking about but my
favorite one of these three though it's
the third one it's called phantoms of
deep and the thing is doctor who doesn't
actually do underwater stuff all that
often I I would suspect at least a part
of that has to do with how awful the
fifth doctor episode warriors of the
deep was and how much that actually
long-term damaged the the show and you
potentially depending on how you want to
look at it may have ultimately led to
some of the forces that wanted the show
to end and be canceled which you know
took a little while to play out but yeah
so I I have a feeling like there's a
certain sense of we just like underwater
stuff's a bad idea for us we just don't
want to talk about which is a shame
because it's a wonderfully moody setting
so we're most of this is taking place
this one's actually a slight future
setting and we're dealing with a
submarine that is exploring a deep-sea
trench and there is some stuff down
there that you wouldn't expect and what
I love about this one this one's
actually I would actually call this one
scary through the use of atmosphere
primarily it does a really good job at
having you feel confined within this
within the submarine and the sense of
isolation and of the danger of just you
know where the characters are is very
palpable and it also does a really good
job of stretching out how long we know
what the threat is and I don't mean how
long before they reveal that ultimately
it's aliens because it's Doctor Who so
it's always aliens but I mean how long
before we even really know that there is
a definitive threat beyond just the
environment we're in and you would think
that that would mean that it's dull and
it doesn't get going for a while but
actually does because that sense of
atmosphere and that sense of anything
that is even slightly off is an
indication of potentially huge danger
that's there almost from the beginning
so long before we start encountering the
titular you know phantoms which some
character
see and some don't you walk before
anybody encounters any of that it still
has a sense of danger about it and
isolation and claustrophobia you know as
well as as an audio medium can can
exhibit those kinds of qualities and
it's done really really well and it's
it's paced really well for what it is to
and I it's funny you know I mentioned
that these are shorter these are only
about an hour apiece and I think that
actually can work very well for isolated
standalone stories because I do think
that definitely the latter two of these
that I'm talking about are stronger than
either one of the larger scale stories
that I talked about last time were from
this same season the antimatter is a
little bit more light and fluffy so I'm
not sure I would say that one is better
than say the Dalek contract in the final
phase but I do feel that these other two
are because you you can have something
be be a one-off and you can well you can
have it be midnight basically not not to
imply that phantoms of the deep is quite
on the level of something like midnight
but it's kind of going for that kind of
vibes like look we're dealing with
weirdness
they just got to survive this this is
not part of a bigger thing we just got
to get out of this situation and it
captures all that really really really
well canines back online for this one
and he's used quite effectively in this
and the supporting cast which is the
crew of the of the submarine plus
another character who I don't really
want to talk too much about because
that's that's kind of getting into a
little bit of spoilers about what they
encountered down there but it's it's
really really well done I was impressed
how well it managed to capture through
audio only the sense of atmosphere of a
creepy ghostly dark underwater setting I
was really impressed with this one so
overall these that all three of these
are good I take enjoyment I love all of
them um with the exception of phantoms
of the deep I'm not sure any of them
believe the impact of like the best of
Big Finish
that I've heard so far I'm not sure
there there's something that I would
I would be like oh yeah if you listen to
Big Finish you gotta be sure you do
those but they are ones that I would
still recommend you know past and
possibly even like as little starting
samples things like they're not as
intimidating and some of the main range
stuff you know which is more than a
berhad of two hours and usually a lot
more involved story-wise these are a
little bit more like little samples
little tasters but they're still really
well done so these three episodes of Big
Finish have you heard any of them have
you heard any other Big Finish ones you
want to recommend that are more so to
these short snackie er bite-sized kind
of things whatever your thoughts are
drop something down the comments let's
talk about it whole bunch of stuff you
can do because it's buns and there's
links including one to my patreon if you
feel like supporting me that way if you
don't don't worry about it other links
you can check out Donal click on them
don't even worry about that either
because you know what end of the day
folks you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]